[Music]
so today's lecture
during this 45 minutes i will talk about
the overview of privacy research in
machine learning and i will focus on
differentiated privacy um i will give
you some basic tutorial on differential
privacy and then i will give you an
example of
how deep learning could be combined with
differential privacy
now uh i will end my lecture with some
interesting trade-offs between the
privacy notion differential privacy and
other emerging notions in ml
uh such as fairness interpretability and
causality
[Music]
i just want to make sure
all right um
[Music]
so the first first part is about
overview okay
so
i
guess there's nobody who doesn't have a
computer or email address these days
right so if you don't have in any of
these you will probably not sit here
listening to this lecture
nowadays all of us can see that more and
more devices collect stream our data
right i mean if you can afford this kind
of smart appliances at home
these machines actually collect your
data right and then stream stream these
to uh the company server and if you can
also afford a drone like this right you
can collect a lot of data without
getting consent from the people
you know whose images are captured
[Music]
now the worry is that only a few
corporations on our data and
we don't know what they're doing
internally right so
it's it's possible they might abuse them
and
it is very clear that they are using
them for their own
benefit but what worries us is that we
don't know we have no control over our
own data
if you read
articles like this probably you're not
going to be
happy to bind this like alexa or things
like this so in this article they said
amazon employed
thousands of people to listen to your
alexa conversations and in this article
um
there was a
children's smart toy called kyla
and that was supposed to be you know
like a good toy at home you know that
can have a like interactive conversation
with your children
but you know the issue is that they
stream the conversation to the company
server
and um anybody who has bluetooth
connection was able to hack this doll of
course these these dolls are not on the
market anymore but all of these
examples make us a little bit you know
oh no so can i actually buy any smart
devices yeah you are worried about your
own privacy so as a computer scientist
we we can definitely work on
developing privacy-preserving
technologies to protect people's privacy
including ours
but these technologies are also
good it can be really
useful for a public good
in this ted talk mallory freeman talks
about the importance of sharing data for
public good
um
so
the title of her talk was your company's
data could help end board hunger right
so it's
quite grandiose and it seems very
important
um in fact using um data for public good
uh
has a name this kind of movement has a
name that's called data philanthropy
it was proposed by united nations global
purse
and i got the
i brought this quote from the director
of u.n global pers
so the the what it says is um we should
think about big data as a new kind of
natural resource
infinitely renewable increasingly
ubiquitous
but um unfortunately at the moment most
of them have fallen into the hands of
industry right
but we should realize that data has a
social opportunity and we have a social
responsibility
and it is our job to make sure that data
reaches the people who need it most and
i really agree with this person um on
this um
and that's why i'm working on also uh
privacy ring machine learning
and i hope you also feel that okay not
only this is good for protecting our
privacy it has good intention um
you know further along the way so let's
first look at the
current state of um status current state
of research in machine learning so we
typically look at several privacy
settings in machine learning um the
simplest possible scenario is where the
sensitive privacy-sensitive data is
located in one location and then
um
you can run some privacy preserving
algorithm
and you release the model
so for instance let's say the private
sensitive data was
covered in 19 patients records yeah
and you run this algorithm
and then the output could be
uh the classifier that can uh determines
based on symptoms or whatever input
features right
whether this person has copied 19 or not
and
another example is um well you have the
same sensitive data but you can also run
some algorithm that could give you
some synthetic data
so because this is a synthetic data you
can just release it without worrying
about
any individual's privacy because there's
no link to any anybody
[Music]
right because this isn't that it
um
in these scenarios uh people often use
this notion called differential privacy
and we will talk about this thing in
detail today
and of course there are other privacy
settings in machine learning where now
the data
stays in two different places or
multiple in
in multiple different places
um and sometimes they want to
communicate with each other but maybe
not necessarily giving data to each
other but some statistics computed on
their data might be
you know shared
or sometimes you might have some third
party
who who does all the computes but you
share your
certain statistics to this server to
train a model together and so on
and in these scenarios uh there are a
lot of other techniques for instance
cryptograph
based encryption and decryption
technologies
or homomorphic encryptions and secure
multiparty computation so on so if you
are interested in learning more about
this use these words to find relevant
papers
um
but as i mentioned uh earlier i will
only focus on differential privacy today
okay so
i usually ask when i give a talk i
usually ask how many people know about
differential privacy
i guess
i guess i cannot do that right
so differential privacy in plain english
is
the statistical science of trying to
learn
as much as possible about a group
while learning very little as little as
possible about any individual in it
it seems a bit conflicting right
but let's look at this cartoon so there
is a data set one um
that includes a lot of people's
information maybe they that includes
these people's medical records
um and you can imagine um
a data matrix right so where each row
corresponds to uh each person in the
data
um
data set and then each column
corresponds to the features or you know
a type of records about that individual
and this d1
contains many people's records like that
as well as alice's record
and given d1 if you run a randomized
algorithm
you the output you might get looks like
this
so it's randomized so every time you run
it you get different outputs so this is
in the output space what is the um
you know output domain and then this is
the output you can get so this output
distribution
and now let's look at another data set
d2
d2 contains
everybody's information exact same way
as before as d1 but now i'm going to
replace alice's data alice's record to
bob's record
so there is one entry difference between
these two data sets
and we sometimes call this neighboring
data sets so
yeah
and then given d2 i'm going to run this
randomized algorithm the same one again
and what i hope to get is somewhat
similar wizard
as before
why because
um if an adversary
who has an access to these outputs right
by looking at these two outputs this
adversary cannot distinguish whether
analysis
was in a data set or bubbles in the data
set
assuming that this adversary knows
everybody else's record
more formally in differential privacy we
look at this particular quantity called
privacy loss
privacy loss is low probability ratio
where the first probability is the
probability of the algorithm a given
data set d1 outputting a particular
output
and the second probability is the
probability of a
the algorithm given data set d2 so
remember the data set d1 and d2 have a
one entry difference and they are
neighboring
that algorithm outputting this exact
same output all
um
so what this says is
well this privacy loss this quantity
tells you
how well we can distinguish two
different data sets
imagine
in some cases you have a large
difference in these two probabilities
right then from adversaries point of
view
well it's clear that something changed
right and
it's easier to guess that somebody's
data changed from this to that right
whether
on the other hand if these two
probabilities are very
very similar to each other
that that
that kind of
distinction will be harder
so formerly
differential privacy in differential
privacy
when this
absolute value of the privacy loss so
it's this whole thing
is bounded by epsilon
where this boundary holds for all
possible outputs all
as well as all pairs of neighboring data
sets
then we say this algorithm is epsilon
differentially private
okay
so in practice how do we even apply this
this notion right um
well the easiest way is you can
add randomness to the output of your
algorithm
so then the question is oh like
randomness what kind of randomness is it
you know that there are multiple
mechanisms i will talk about later but
whatever mechanism we are talking about
in the end the noise variance has to be
uh proportional to
uh this quantity
something called uh sensitivity
and the other quantity
that we saw before the upper bound to
the privacy laws right
so um what happened is
if your algorithm is sensitive in this
sense so sensitivity is defined in this
way
if
the maximum difference between the
outputs of these two uh
outputs of the algorithms given these
two neighboring data sets yeah when
there is only one entry difference
so if your algorithm happens to be very
sensitive to this kind of change
then to conceal that difference right
you want to add more noise
so in a way it makes sense
and another quantity here is inverse
inversely proportional to the uh privacy
laws um so the way you think about this
is
uh
if you allow for larger privacy laws
yeah
that means you don't need to add so much
noise in an extreme case right if you
just let everybody know about your data
you don't need to add any noise right
then epsilon goes to infinity yeah then
the additive noise scale becomes zero
right
on the other hand if you want if you
don't want to allow any privacy loss you
want it's going to be very very very
very small let's say 10 to negative 6
then the noise variance you have to
consider
should be really large
so it also makes sense right this kind
of relationship
but the problem is because we are adding
some additional noise and that depends
on privacy loss inversely and also
uh sensitivity um
you have a um
[Music]
this inevitable trade-off between
privacy and accuracy
so i made this a cartoon
you are cranking up the privacy loss if
you allow for larger and larger privacy
loss your accuracy of some algorithm
will reach the
non-private
algorithms accuracy right
but um
in practice what we want to do as a
machine learning researcher
we want to develop a
machine learning algorithm that privacy
that that preserves privacy
uh that gives you a relatively good
accuracy as well as
a relatively reasonable level of privacy
and i mean here a reasonable level is
kind of an open question and it depends
on the application what epsilon
is reasonable
there are a lot of studies on this thing
but
let's just keep it this way and then we
move on
and here i will talk about two different
differentially private mechanisms that
are really widely used so the first one
is called laplace mechanism
well as the name suggests we are adding
noise drawn from a laplace distribution
um let's think about this easy example
very simple example uh suppose my data
set
contains um
monthly salary of n different
individuals right so x i x one means
uh first person's uh monthly salary yeah
and etc
and then um
i don't know which country this is but
in this country yeah the unit
this salary is always
between zero and 300. so nobody gets uh
more than 300.
um and the output i want to uh produce
is the average salary of these people
right so this is the formula for average
and i'm not sure if i want to just
release this theme so i'm going to make
this
as differentially private by adding
laplace noise do you remember the noise
scale has to be proportional to
sensitivity
divided by privacy loss right so this is
exactly what we saw before
s is the sensitivity defined this way in
this way
um
okay so in this example
computing sensitivity is relatively easy
right
um
but we can go back to that i think uh
for the sake of
for the interest of time um i will not
talk about this in detail but
when when these um each data point it
has this limited um
uh
input domain then it's typically easy to
compute the sensitivity it's even
analytic analytically retractable in
this simple example
uh so you can find the
noise noise scale easily but in in some
cases there is unbounded sensitivity and
they are also worked on
to handle this kind of situation
some of you might think
okay i guess this is how it is but i
actually want to prove proof that by
adding this much noise it is actually
epsilon dp
average
well so i prepared some uh derivation so
we look at the definition of
differential privacy right
there we talked about privacy loss it
was log of this one but let's just think
about exponentiated this
probability
uh
ratio
and
because we added laplace noise right the
output of this mechanism
follows the laplace distribution where
the mean is now shifted right
so shifted mean and the scale is the
same but we are
evaluating this thing at a particular
output all right
and
if you use the inverse triangle
inequality
revert is it inverse no not reverse
inverse
um
the the the opposite of the user uh
triangular inequality
um i don't remember the name but uh
you can get this upper bound right and
then well we saw this thing s is nothing
but the sensitivity definition so you
can easily bound this thing by if soon
remember this this should hold for all
possible value of all and all possible
um
neighboring data set
x and x
prime yeah
and
so laplace mechanism give you this
epsilon differentially private
output
another widely used mechanism is called
gaussian mechanism so here you add noise
from drawn from gaussian distribution
right
here but there's slight difference um
from the plus mechanism
[Music]
here the noise variant noise scale is
again something similar to the previous
one right so you have the sensitivity of
your function you're computing divide by
the privacy loss but there is some
constant here c of delta
so what does it mean
okay i think we will go back to this
thing um
all right so
what this constant says is basically
you know what because um in this
gaussian case you are adding noise but
um this privacy loss is not always
bounded by epsilon sometimes it can be
larger than epsilon but don't worry that
probability
will be bounded by delta it cannot be
larger than delta right so this delta
can be viewed as a failure probability
this gives you this notion of
approximate differential privacy so this
by adding this gaussian noise the
release value
is
epsilon delta differentially private so
that means this pure
differential privacy definition
um
holds with probability at least one
minus delta
so there is a difference between laplace
and gaussian mechanism and one gives you
the guarantee of pure dp the other one
gives you the approximate tp guarantee
pure dp is nothing but epsilon dp
it's just a word that people use and um
for the sake of time um
for the interest of time i was actually
okay wait a second quick clarification
shouldn't noise be directly
proportionate to privacy laws as well
remember this privacy laws is actually
allowed private a lot what you are
allowing um
what you are allowing so if you are
allowing large uh privacy loss
uh that means
you don't need to add so much noise
so that's the that's the logic um why
this has to be
inversely proportional to
the luigi scale
okay so we talked about two different
mechanisms but there are a lot more
mechanisms you can definitely look at
this um
this book this book is actually pretty
well written
um of course this was written in 2014 so
these they are not like a lot of new
works are not included but it gives you
re the i mean as the name suggests the
the true foundations for differential
privacy
so if you're interested in this topic
read at least for three chapters of this
book then you'll feel uh okay now i have
some background and then i can start
looking into more
recent work
okay
and then uh two important properties of
differential privacy before we move into
the
more applications of dp to deep learning
the first property is called
post-processing invariance
so what it means is differential privacy
is immune to post-processing
so we we
we saw this thing a lot today right so
suppose there is a sensitive data set
private sensitive data set and then you
run an epsilon dp algorithm
for instance you add gaussian noise to
some some value you computed on this
data data
and
you have another algorithm that takes
the output of this epsilon ep algorithm
and the output of this algorithm
is epsilon dp
with respect to the sensitive data
okay this is called post-processing
invariance
so in a way if you release this um
the the the privatize the salary right
salary average salary people can use
this thing to do other things without
worrying about the privacy of those
people who are in the
original data set
and another property important property
is called compatibility
this means
if you access the sensitive data twice
say
once by using this epson one dp
algorithm
the other time using its own two dp
algorithm
the union of these two outputs
is epsilon one plus six from two dp
right so your privacy loss increases
the more you access the data
and in fact this upper bound is
pessimistic and there are better upper
bounds
when you compose these
dp mechanisms um
so if you're interested you can look at
this paper
so we talked about post-processing
invariance and also composition
property of dp
but this composition property is what
makes the uh you know applying dp to ml
algorithms very challenging because a
lot of ml algorithms are iterative
meaning it access data over and over and
over right
like the the the most um
obvious example will be stochastic
gradient descent when you do deep
learning training right
so
yeah
so there is a
high challenge in that
how to privatize deep learning training
okay so now we move to deep generative
modeling with differential privacy
in this example we will go to
the task of
generating synthetic data
in a privacy preserving manner right
so the goal is
i want to transform this privacy
sensitive data
to
non-sensitive ones so synthetic data
but at the same time i want to keep
these two data sets statistical
properties the same
or similar in some sense
i will look at the q and a
okay this is not a quick thing to answer
so i will continue um
so classical approaches for
data generation with differential
privacy typically assume a particular
query class
if it's a linear query that means
for instance it could be the sum of data
points that's what they are they want to
release and and so on right
and
they
had a lot of papers were
a
theory-based paper and they had a like
formal guarantee on the usefulness of
the synthetic data
for
that particular query class that are
assumed um
but the problem is if you want to use
this uh synthetic data right for other
tasks uh then outside of this particular
query class says were assumed initially
then there is no formal guarantee
anymore and then definitely it lacks
flexibility
so
deep learning people came into this
differential privacy field and they
thought
wow this is an easy problem to solve
let's just use again because again you
can produce anything you want right i
mean this is true but
um
it is hard to find a good privacy and
accuracy trade-off if you scan
i can tell you why um and there are
several works done that try to uh you
know combine differential privacy for
gan training
before going to that i will just give
you a very uh brief recap of what ken is
i believe all of you read heard about it
many many times this week
so again
has a generator right generator takes
some random input
from a known
distribution say gaussian
and then it generator transforms z
to
data sample
yeah x tilde is generated data
and then discriminator looks at this
generated data and the real data and
tells you whether
uh they are similar or not or fake or
not you know
um
and i'm i brought
the most basic laws that get paper used
initially um
and there's a max um
optimization right here
um
i mean for us for you know privacy
people what's important is in your loss
function who is actually looking at the
data who has access to data
who has to access the data
well only discriminator sees the real
data right in this case but
generator never sees the data
so
people thought okay then let's perturb
the gradients of the discriminator
for privacy
and
because of the post-processing
invariance of vp
the trend generator is also dp with
respect to the training data
and this particular way of
privatizing the gain
this is called a dpsgd
this can be also used for any other
models basically what it does is add
certain amount of noise to a stochastic
gradient descent step right but the
problem is
you do this gradient perturbation in
every learning step and you are not
going to train again within within the
epoch right so you have to
train this over and over for many many
uh epochs
and this results in high privacy laws
and as we saw before due to the
composibility of dp
also
cans are usually like a big architecture
right they usually have a big
architecture and the parameters number
of parameters for discriminator
is uh
pretty much large and that means it has
also larger sensitivity um
so yeah in the end combine these two
like compatibility and the large
architecture
just simply applying dpscg
to gans doesn't work
and some people realize that hey i mean
but you're using gans and try to just
like
you know produce amnes digits or fashion
numbness
images and so on
um and they cannot really go to uh more
complex data like c410 or imagenet
because epsilon
you know the required epsilon is so high
there's no like practical sense of
privacy protection there so they are
somehow bound to these very simplistic
data sets
and try to use scans for that and it
doesn't make so much sense and then if
you try to use against you have to add
noise to the gradient in a regenerating
step so it's not going well with dp so a
lot of people realize that you know what
um why don't you just uh
use a fixed discriminator
in other words why don't you use a fixed
features
fixed set of features that are that you
don't learn from the data
to judge the similarity between rear and
synthetic data because if you use a
fixed set of features that are not
learned from data there's no privacy
loss in it right so the only way only
place you have to pay privacy budget to
is for training the discriminator
and uh here are some examples so this dp
merv and dp synchron these two papers
use this idea that we are going to use
the fixed set of
features
that are not learned from the data on
the other hand this dpc gain is one type
of gain that basically produces images
condition on so c means condition on the
labels
here to ensure the privacy guarantee
they
use tpsgd so every in every training
step you add noise to the gradients of
the discriminator
and these are the images produced for
epsilon 10 yeah
all of them
um and well by eyes you can see okay i
guess the bottom two are better than the
first one
and another way of more
quantitatively
evaluate the usefulness of the synthetic
data is
you can train a classifier using the
synthetic data generated data in each
case right
and then test the
trained
let's say logistic regression uh
classifier on the real data test
real test data so that means you want to
see how
well uh generalize your synthetic data
to real data in this sense right and
these are the numbers so if you use this
fixed uh set of um
features to generate these uh images
you get about like 75.5 percent test
accuracy um on the other hand if you use
this uh tpc gain you get like 50 test
accuracy which is significantly lower
than the other two right
but then the problem is while you are
actually comparing these two in this
very simplistic data sets
so here it makes sense that you are
using some fixed set of features
works well
but if your data is more complex then
this idea doesn't work in fact there's a
new work um uh
which is available in an archive this is
actually our work
that tries to uh
um
generate c410 images right this is a
real data samples
um
and if you use this the fixed picture uh
features it
and these are the samples you can see
um these are quite terrible right
nothing close to these images
but um
so this paper basically suggests that
why don't we use some public data to
pre-train a feature extractor network
and then we compare
two data distributions
uh in terms of those features
and if you do that you can actually get
images like this for
a reasonable at a reasonable privacy
budget
and fid score already tells you this is
a lot better than the other right so
definitely there is a
more work to be done to improve
this aspect
to try to find a good balance between
privacy and accuracy uh in the context
of um
like high dimensional data generation
image generation
i will quickly check q a if there is any
quick
question i could answer
[Music]
okay i will move on
and then um
the last 10 minutes or so i will talk
about the
differential privacy without other you
know how differential privacy interacts
with other emerging notions in ml
so there are three different notions i
will talk about um
fairness
interpretability and causality
um
[Music]
you might wonder when you see this thing
if you don't know anything about
fairness or interpretability or in
causality you might wonder how is even
privacy interact with them i mean what
do you mean by interact and what do you
mean by trade-off like how
right it's going to be a little bit
bizarre so i will give you a concrete
example
there are i must say um in these
intersections there are a lot of work
done recently because these are all new
um new concepts right the
interpretability of like black box
models and so on or fairness
yeah these are very new uh
ideas and uh very new research topics
uh what i'm giving you is
a tip of ice iceberg big iceberg so you
just listen to what what i'm talking
about today but please go to those
suggested readings uh i put in in my
slide
and to get more you know to learn more
about these things
um
they are quite exciting um and very
different from what was studied before
so the first example i will look into
this paper
fair decision making using privacy
protective data
to talk about fairness and privacy
trade-off
so the task they considered was um
educational funds or location using u.s
census data
um
so i didn't know about this but
apparently
u.s census bureau
releases
census data that includes a lot of
population statistics
and the government agents other
government agencies uses use this
population statistics
to determine uh how much money they will
use for
whatever you know like welfare
for u.s citizens
so one example
uh
this paper actually talked about several
examples but i will only focus on one
example task um
so that's basically educational funded
location that takes um
these population statistics released by
u.s census bureau and
uh the goal is to make decisions on how
to distribute funds to offer educational
assistance to disadvantaged children
so there is a huge responsibility right
in using this statistic correctly
and
if you just use the statistic
rose's statistic
there is a privacy uh concern so
people started using um
differential private uh mechanisms in
u.s census bureau but in this paper they
talked about two different mechanisms
one is just like a very simple laplace
mechanism
to add noise to the
statistics right or they also talked
about more advanced one but uh we will
not talk about this thing
in this talk and this finding is quite
interesting so the door is added to
achieve privacy
disproportionately impact some groups
over others
and if your privacy constraint
is more stringent
then this phenomenon gets more
pronounced
okay
so
this is the table they showed let's look
at this thing um
they considered um
it's basically they are comparing the
true allocation from the location if you
don't add any noise to the statistics
and then you follow some formula the u.s
government uses right for
educational fund or location
and you have the true allocation based
on that
and if you add noise
at epsilon 0.1 level that means you add
a lot of noise versus if you add noise
a lot less right because it's known as
10
and they saw what happens uh
on the uh what happens in this
allocation
fund location
in terms of
in small districts and large districts
small large means in terms of the
population who are eligible for this
benefit
what they found was smaller districts
receive inflated allocation of funds so
this times means actually
more than 10 times more than um
non-private allocation fund yeah a
location and then this is 1.01 so that
means
uh your um
when your privacy budget is high right
when you allow for larger privacy loss
then the difference between non-private
allocation and private or location is
not so high but
if your privacy constraint is really
strong
then you have a 10 times more
funder located for this small district
on the other hand the largest district
actually had a different problem they
actually got the lower
amount of
uh funds so what happened is why is this
even related to fairness it's because
uh in the end they got this money right
for a small district and larger district
um and they allocate this thing to each
student right
but then that means per student benefit
for larger district is significantly
lower than
a per student benefit in the small
district so this is unfair uh for each
student right
so that's what they found and actually
other similar findings were also
observed here differential privacy has
disparate impact on model accuracy so
here they talked about moderate
inaccuracy increases
for
underrepresented groups
once you add the differential privacy
mechanisms in your training uh of your
like deep classifier
and there are other further readings on
privacy uh fairness accuracy uh sorry
trade-off and there's also very nice
tutorial on fairness so
i didn't actually talk about fairness uh
agreed to make fairness notions at all
here uh but there are a lot to learn uh
just for fairness itself
um and then i will also briefly talk
about interpretability privacy trade-off
um by looking at this particular paper
so people started looking into
interpretability because a lot of people
were saying okay the black box models
are really useful they have a really
high
accuracy in classification right
but
they don't know why
the classifier says you will die or you
will get a heart attack within like
you know within like 30 days based on
your medical records so far and so on
right so you want to actually understand
why this black box model makes such a
decision and there is a one
very well known and widely used
interpretability
method called lime it's
it stands for local interpretability
model agnostic explanations
um this is how it works uh it uses a
relatively simple surrogate model for
instance this first linear model that
can give you a very um
uh
briefs
it can give you a local summary of the
explanation about
a complex black box model um
so let's look at an example so they
train a uh inception network um
and then i actually i think they just
downloaded it downloaded in session
network from google
and then there are interested in
why or whether
if this network says this is a dog or
a guitar right it can be anything
and it wants to know why that classifier
makes that such a decision
to do that
uh they wrote down this kind of loss
function
where g is
for instance you can be anything
actually but in this particular example
they use this sparse linear model so
they considered surrogate model as a
linear model
so w is the parameter and z is some z
prime is some input
and then f is the
complex black box model so you want the
output of these two models to be similar
right because you are minimizing this
thing with some weight pi
here z and z prime are the non-zero
elements of x x is this test image
uh drawn uniformly at random so
if you increase the number elements
uh in z that it uh
recovers x so you it conceptually what
it means is
there is a test point i want to
understand and then i basically have
some
uh
sample around this around this test
point
uh and then this weight
is could be something like um you know
if this l this d is uh l2 distance this
could be viewed as a uh like exponential
kernel right
uh
squared exponential corner anyways what
it says is if my candidate c is similar
to my test point x then i will give a
higher weight than
the other case so by minimizing this
thing what they found was
when the label was a guitar
actually this w
no you are minimizing this thing for w
and actually there is another constraint
that uh in forces sparsity in w
um the recovered w is basically this
area pointing at this area so that means
okay this black box model says this is
guitar because this is focusing on here
right on the other hand when the label
was a dog
you can see
the
in this case using this label right and
minimizing this thing gives you this
particular w that points at um the face
of the dog
so it's a very nice way of like getting
an interpretation
at around the test point you are
interested in so that's why they are
using this word local explanation
um local meaning that at that particular
test point
so this paper model explanations with
differential privacy uses some something
similar to this lime objective we just
look into
um for privacy they added notes to the
gradients during training
i mean it's a little bit more
complicated than that but overall it's
gradient perturbation
and the evaluation metric is in the
following so the objective function
given the non-private explanation
uh they computed this thing and also
they computed expected objective
function given privatized explanations
and they look at these gaps
right
uh and then they say if the gap is large
that means you are your explanation
privatize explanation is farther away
from a non-private explanation this is a
metric they used and they look at three
different data sets and
they evaluate this metric at two
different epsilon values it's not one
it's 1.1
if i'm sorry if some 0.01 and it's on
0.1
and as you
increase the privacy constraint here
right
this
distance this gap gets larger
than when epsilon was 0.1
another thing so if this is point of
interest so basically if your test point
is like this
sorry if your
test point is like this and if you
uh have very small epsilon allowed very
small epsilon then your explanation has
almost no meaning there is no visual or
cue right you cannot understand what
this is but as you increase epsilon you
allow for larger and larger privacy loss
then
the
explanation becomes more visually
recognizable
yeah okay
of course there are similar findings
i guess people are all thinking very
similarly
so here is the another paper you can
look into um
and further reading on interpretability
and privacy trade-off here right
and there's a very nice uh
interpretability tutorial on
interpretability methods um this was in
icml 2017.
okay now um
i wanted to talk about also causality
privacy trade-off but
for the interest of time i will only
give you the reading suggestions so
please take a look
and i will wrap up my
lecture uh by
summarizing what was discussed today the
first one we talked about differential
privacy um
people
love this uh people even say this is
like a gold standard privacy notion
because of this probable guarantee right
and then we always have to make sure
that the particular algorithm you
develop has to uh satisfy this upper
bound the privacy loss upper bound
epsilon
we talked about two different properties
um
and two different example mechanisms we
also talked about um differentially
private um
generative general modeling
um
also we talked about the trade-offs
between differential privacy and other
notions in machine learning
okay
so thank you for your attention
thank you mijon uh for the great talk um
we have a couple of questions in the q
and a chat uh the first one is from
tamiya um the question is are there
contrastive process to differential
privacy uh that is enforcing the same
output for any one percent substitution
in the in some population drawn from the
data set
i could use the population and one step
population as the positive pair and
using different populations to create
negative pairs
this is a very good
so i don't i don't think i've ever seen
such a formulation um
i think the problem is though
um
this is talking about like given a data
set right you are
removing one person and then have a
positive example and then negative is an
example and you know in this contrasting
learning sense but then
the problem is this privacy laws
has to
satisfied let me go back
it's a bit hard to
do you see this um
right so this privacy loss has to be
satisfied for all possible alphas of all
and also pairs of data sets so it's
actually
let's say you remove one person from the
data right
but somebody can always give you another
data point that can
make the uh
change the upper bound
so um
in a way this is not
actually um
but of course there is also like a paper
on
um differential privacy using this local
data your own data and then just
changing one person from the data
but this is actually not um consistent
with the original
definition of differential privacy
because it has to satisfy uh for all
possible pairs of neighboring data sets
um
i hope this is clear
okay thanks for the answer
um simon has another question if this is
synthesized data lacks diversity could
it be biased against certain subgroups
of the population is there a trade-off
between data privacy and data fairness
yeah this is a very good question um
so people usually talk about the
fairness privacy trade-off in the
context of classification
um
but yeah i
i mean i don't know
off the top of my head uh what the
correct answer is
but this is definitely something you
know interesting to look into
thanks
um
the next question is from leonard if we
use this fixed set of features not learn
from data where do we train on the data
and can you give an example of fixed
status a fixed set of features
yeah this is actually a very good
question so i mean for the interest of
time i actually didn't talk about this
thing um
do you see my screen still right yes
um
so
the dpmurph paper for instance
they use this uh
random free features
um
it's basically you you can embed your
data in this um
something like just imagine this as like
some random projection
yeah so you embed this to some some
random projection but if you have like a
lot of dimensions you know
which where you project your data onto
then um you can kind of cover uh
different frequencies if you analyze
this thing in um
in
in free domain right so
you don't learn this uh random
projection from the data you just uh you
know consider like sufficiently large
number of um
projections
uh
but this simple thing can still like you
know generate this kind of amnesia and
this data
uh
a better way than training against with
dp sgd
okay thanks um
for the next question from is from
nicola um in the context of releasing
privacy protected data using generated
generative models do you see other
possible solutions beside differential
privacy
i don't i don't know actually i don't
know
um if you want to actually share data
right then there are ways to do that you
can
use
cryptography based um
[Music]
techno techniques like encryption
decryption and then you actually agree
on certain
protocols and you share data
um
but if you want to generate using deep
learning
um
yeah
i'm not sure
okay um
um our next question is uh because can
we say that the sharpness
of their optimizers are
differential
differential
um privacy friendly
oh i don't know what sharpness or
optimizer is
not because i'm not very sure um
i will google it today and then i will
answer it tomorrow during the faculty
mixer yeah sorry about that
okay uh now we have
i guess time for last question
from eric
what do you think about using partial
observability as a privacy preservation
method
[Music]
pressure observability
yeah i will also think about this thing
um
i said it's not so easy to uh answer by
the way
can we actually look at the last one
it depends on the accuracy of the model
since the additional privacy has an
impact on accuracy
could we be facing an accuracy privacy
interpreter yes definitely definitely
because you're adding noise right i mean
there's actually a triangle um so you
traditionally you only talked about like
accuracy and privacy tradeoff and uh if
you add interpretability in it right
you by adding noise your
interoperability suffers as well as
accuracy
um
and if you ask like is there any any
other
way to find the balance between all
three
i believe so and
[Music]
the other paper one of this paper that
you know similar findings the paper is
uh trying to find that balance
so maybe you want to look into that
okay
i guess we'll wrap it up thank you again
i'm joined for the great talk um
we're happy to have you here
[Music]
you